[Musique]
bonsoir à tout
bonsoir à tous alors avant de commencer
j'aimerais vous poser une question qui
ci a déjà été dernier de la classe
résine et pente lever la main ceux qui
ont déjà été dernier de la classe
durant leur scolarité à y en a
quelques-uns quand même je vous pose la
question parce que comme j'étais au ce2
au deuxième trimestre j'ai été 4e de ma
classe sur 25
alors c'est vrai quatrième c'est pas
dernière mais je l' ai vécu exactement
comme si c'était le cas d'une part parce
qu'avant j'avais toujours été premières
et surtout d'autre part parce que je
savais que j'avais les ressources
nécessaires pour continuer d'être
première de la classe
mais en grandissant j'ai appris à
connaître une dernière de classe qui ne
s'émouvait pas vraiment de sa situation
comme moi j'étais quatrième j'étais en
pleurs c'était un véritable drame
je me rouler par terre mais cette
dernière de classe on lui dit
régulièrement qu'elle est dernière de
classe et elle ne s'en émeut pas
vraiment vous la connaissez tous ici
c'est l'afrique c'est vrai de façon
régulière les institutions
internationales disent d'alaric tuer la
dernière du classement en termes de
développement et puis quelques années
plus tard on lui dit encore tu es
toujours la dernière du classement et
personne n'est un console à personne se
roule par terre personne ne pleure alors
moi j'ai décidé de demander mon voir et
puis de chercher à comprendre pourquoi
on en était là et surtout comment faire
pour s'en sortir
donc j'ai cherché j'ai lu et entre deux
lectures je suis tombé sur le film black
panther black panther pour ceux d'entre
vous qui était en voyage hors de la
planète terre cette année qu'ils n'ont
pas vu c'est un film qui parle d'un pays
africain fictif qu'ils appellent le
wakanda et le rwanda est un pays qui est
largement en avance sur le reste du
monde parce qu'il possède une ressource
particulière un matériau spécial qui
s'appelle le vivre à niort retenez bien
ce nom
le vibranium permet donc aux candidats
de développer des technologies
extraordinaire et si ce n'était pas une
fiction
et si comme le dit la bible les derniers
seront les premiers
si le l'afrique était un roi candidats
en attente de réalisation alors je
comprends bien vous êtes en train de
vous dire oui mais quelle serait notre
vibranium ça on en reparle tout à
l'heure avant j'aimerais vous inviter à
faire avec moi un constat et pour faire
ce constat je vais vous présenter deux
jeunes hommes le premier que vous voyez
à l'écran s'appelle mamadou nama doit
une quinzaine d'années il va à l'école
en moré il parle couramment le monde le
sait sa langue maternelle
mamadou a droit tous les matins au petit
déjeuner à un bol de bouillie de petit
mil et puis quand vous lui demandez
quels sont les grands classiques
littéraires et musicaux mamadou vous
parle de cheikh anta diop amadou hampaté
bâ il vous parle la mélodie de youssou
ndour et de la musique de georges
ouédraogo
maintenant j'aimerais vous présenter
nicolas
nicolas également une quinzaine d'années
dans l'école en français par couramment
le français
c'est sa langue maternelle et nicolas a
droit à un bol de céréales tous les
matins au petit déjeuner quand vous lui
demandez de citer les grands classiques
littéraires et musicaux nicolas vous
parlera volontiers de molière de la
fontaine et vous citera la musique de
géniale idée celle de jacques brel
pourquoi et que je suis trompé vous
croyez que j'ai interverti les photos
absolument pas et vous avez regardé ma
doué ou je vous ai entendu et je sais
que vous vous êtes dit mais quelle est
l'histoire particulière de ce jeune
homme comment on peut avoir cette tête
là s'appelait mamadou parler mort etc
mais nicolas je sais qu'il ne vous a pas
impressionnés par ce que vous êtes
entouré de nicolas et c'est justement là
le constat que je voulais vous inviter à
faire avec moi c'est que nous sommes les
seuls au monde
c'est à dire l'afrique est la seule au
monde à vivre et à tenter de se
développer avec des normes qui lui
viennent d'ailleurs des normes qui ne
sont pas les siennes et d'un homme
qu'elle n'est question jamais alors j'ai
une bonne nouvelle pour vous nous ne
sommes pas obligés d'être les derniers
parce que nous avons le vide greniers
homme est dans la vraie vie se vivra n'y
sommes c'est la culture
mais bien entendu les cultures
africaines sont le vibranium je vous
demande pas de me croire sur parole mais
si vous me donnez encore quelques
minutes de votre attention
je pense en tout cas j'espère que vous
serez du même avis que moi alors je
propose trois piliers sur lesquels
l'afrique peut s'appuyer pour prendre
son envol vers la première place en se
basant sur son rib rényon il s'agit dans
un premier temps de l'afro consommation
afro consommer c'est produire
transformer vendre mais aussi acheter
majoritairement et prioritairement
africain pas seulement parce qu'on n'a
pas le choix comme on le voit encore
aujourd'hui mais parce que c'est notre
premier choix imaginez si seulement 50%
de la frite y manger s'habiller se
divertissent et se cultiver
exclusivement par non exclusivement
africain ça changerait la face du monde
et je pèse mes mots et il est la nôtre
vibranium il y a ensuite l'afro
édification la fois édification c'est
bâtir l savoie un africain en réalité il
ne s'agit pas vraiment de le bâtir mais
plus de l'organiser de le diffuser
largement parce qu'il existe ce savoir
et les faces et il est quand on parle de
croo édification ne parle pas
nécessairement d'africaines qui écrivent
ni d'écrire sur l'afrique mais plus de
vraiment bâtir un paradigme africaine
dans lequel on va être capable d'en
racines et nos schémas de pensée nos
protocoles de recherche
imaginez tout ce que nos aïeux avaient
compris avait vu allait analyser
assemblée retranscrits et largement
diffusé ça aussi ça changerait la grâce
du monde et il est là notre vivre à nyon
et puis une fois n'est pas coutume j'ai
commencé par la fin
l'afro éducation et par la base de
l'afro consommation et de l'afro
édification pour bien saisir
l'importance de là foi et éducation il
faut comprendre la notion de
socialisation primaire la socialisation
primaires ce sont les premiers
apprentissages qu'on fait c'est à dire
les apprentissages qu'ils nous disent
qu'ils nous sommes
sont les autres et qui nous initie à des
cotes et à des rituels de comportement
et les sociologues nous disent que cette
socialisation primaire elle nous donne
les lunettes pour regarder le monde et
qu'elle est très difficilement
modifiable par la suite et dans nos
sociétés dites modernes le principal
obtient c'est l'école c'est pour ça que
c'est à l'école que la fois éducation
doit commencer
affreux éduquer concrètement qu'est ce
que ça peut être apprendre les langues
locales
dès le bas âge à l'école et à prendre
par les langues locales
ça peut également être inscrire comme
deuxième et troisième langue dans le
cursus scolaire d'autres langues
africaines
et puis on peut habiller les enfants à
l'école en uniforme basé sur des tissus
africains et je ne parle pas des pagnes
qu'on fabrique en eau l'homme imaginez
si ce soir comme vous êtes arrivé on
vous avait accueilli en vous disant et
watch ou au lieu de bienvenue et que
vous aviez tous été en mesure de
comprendre ça changera la face du monde
et il est là notre uranium
alors je sais ça peut sembler utopique
ou théoriques
donc je vais vous montrer que c'est réel
parce que ça a commencé à se faire et je
vous donner quelques exemples en termes
d'architecturé on retrouve de plus en
plus d'africains qui vont étudier à
l'étranger et qui reviennent sur le
continent pour construire des cités et
des habitations à l'africaine à
l'africaine ça veut dire respectueux de
l'environnement en termes de nature mais
également de l'environnement en termes
de culture de traditions d'habitude et
de mode de vie
ça commence à se faire vous voyez la
grande muraille de chine en eau a été
construite uniquement en matériaux
locaux
c'est une des sept merveilles du monde
elle est visitée par les millions de
personnes donc c'est faisable et même
ici à ouagadougou la cathédrale qui a
été construite au début des années 1930
a été construite uniquement en matériaux
locaux
voyez en bas un plan proposé par un de
ces jeunes architectes africains dont je
parlais je peux également vous citer
l'exemple de ce chocolatier burkinabè
qui a gagné de nombreux prix et qui a
décidé de faire du chocolat africains
donc avec des ingrédients exclusivement
africain ça nous change
le chocolat le cacao est produit pas
loin de chez nous et pourtant on
s'évertue année après année à noël à
pâques à diverses occasions à consommer
du chocolat qui nous vient de l'occident
il ya également cette décision de
l'ouganda en 2016 de rendre obligatoire
l'apprentissage du swahili est la
troisième langue la plus parlée en
afrique après l'arabe et l'anglais est
la première langue africaine la plus
parlée à l'afrique ce soit il y
maintenant en ouganda on l'apprend à
l'école et c'est obligatoire le rwanda
lui un programme qui s'appelle y toreros
et qui est basée sur la tradition
rwandaise et permet la socialisation des
jeunes comme des moins jeunes autour des
valeurs et des traditions et culture
rwandaise
et puis à l'exemple de ce jeune
centrafricain de 23 ans qui a décidé de
faire des jeux vidéos avec des univers
uniquement africain alors vous voyez ça
existe et ça se fait ça commence à se
faire tranquillement je vous disais en
commençant que vous n'aviez pas avoir
honte si vous aviez déjà été dernier de
la classe
et c'est vrai il n'ya aucune honte à
avoir déjà occupé la dernière place par
contre ce serait une véritable honte
pour l'afrique de continuer d'accepter
son classement
soucieuse mans alors qu'elle a tous eu
vibranium toutes ces cultures africaines
riches
l'exemple du rwanda nous montre qu'il
n'y a pas que quelques initiatives mais
qu'à l'échelle d'un pays c'est faisable
le rwanda est passé en 25 ans c'est à
dire une génération du chaos génocide au
rêve
aujourd'hui quand on parle du rwanda on
en parle en terme d' exemple c'est le
phare de l'afrique c'est le grand succès
c'est le bon élève c'est le miracle donc
ça peut se faire puisqu'ils l'ont fait
mais il est nécessaire que ça se fasse à
bien plus grande échelle de l'afrique
entière
si m elle a le gibran y sommes elle peut
le faire
le rappeur kery james ati on dit que
l'union fait la force mais qui fera
l'union
moi je suis convaincu que ma génération
avec tout le vignoble qui est disponible
avec toute cette riche culture africaine
est capable et à même le devoir de faire
en sorte que l'afrique d'école de sa
dernière place au classement et qu'elle
prenne son envol vers la première place
qui contrairement à ce qu'on lui a
toujours dit ne lui est pas inaccessible
si ce soir je j'ai su vous convaincre
que nos cultures était notre vibranium
je vais vous demander de vous lever et
de faire quelque chose avec moi pau
celles et ceux qui ont vu le film black
panther vous connaissez le mouvement que
je veux qu'on fasse mais on va le faire
à notre sauce ça va être africa forever
et paroisse 49 waves est prêt alors on y
va
africa fois je vous remercie aline donc
africa forever